طوابير طويله سعيا للحصول على رغيف خبز
يسد رمقهم وعائلاتهم في ظل حرب اسرائيليه
متواصله وحصار على قطع غزه لم يسبق له
مثيل ومع مرور الساعات واستمرار القصف
وعدم دخول مساعدات غذائيه تزداد مخاوف
السكان من انقطاع ماده الخبز التي يعتمدون
عليها بشكل اساسي في غذائهم
الناس كلها هاجمه على المخابز والمخابز مش
قادره توفر لهم لا طحين ولا ميه ولا غاز
ولا سولر ولا اي حاجه الوضع نقص عنا عننا
صعب الوضع ماساوي جدا واحنا بنطلب من
العالم كله يقف معنا يا عمي الوضع احنا
خطير جدا جدا الوضع خطير احنا اليوم بعد
اليوم ح نسكر الوضع كل ماله اكثرر يعني
اذا قدرنا نوفر اليوم مش ح نوفره بكره
يعني والدار عندي مليان انا عندي تسع
اطفال والحمد لله على كل حال احنا مش
قادرين نوفر ولا اي
حاجه الماء ايضا لم يعد الحصول عليه
سهلا وخلال ايام سيفقد اذا استمر الوضع
الراهن بحسب اصحاب محطات الوقود بسبب عدم
توفر وقود لمولدات الكهرباء التي يحتاجون
اليها لسحب الماء من باطن الارض جاي عب
ميه حلوه للشرب بستخدمها لكل الاستخدامات
هذه اللي انا بلاقيها مش بس للشرب لكل
استخدامات من يوم الحين ان بالضبط اناش
عندي في بيت م خمسه
ايام دمرت اسرائيل منازل الفلسطينيين في
غزه فنزحوا الى مناطق اعتقدوا انها اكثر
امنا لا سما مدارس وكاله غوث وتشغيل
اللاجئين فوجدوا الا مكان امنا في القطاع
وتركتهم وكاله الغوث بلا ماء ولا غذاء ولا
حقهم القصف الاسرائيلي كذلك اينما حل
اطلعنا عن دواز غزه انضربنا هنا رجعنا غزه
انضربنا برضه بغزه كمان لهنا لايش لايش
هذا الاموات قاعدين بتموت وهذا وقلنا طيب
طيب سيبين بيوتنا وحياتنا واولادنا
وعيالنا مرميين كل هيت بناتنا وسونا في
الشوارع هل هذا بيبني كلام زي هذا فيش ولا
اي دوله عربيه مستعده تقف معانا بس تقول
لا اله الا الله احنا على سبيل ايش احنا
قاعدين احنا بنقول
لاف ضري في بيت حنون ياما ماليش حته غيرها
روح فين بعديها روح فين بعديها قالوا
روحوا على على الجنوب رحنا على الجنوب
هينا جينا على انسرات احنا حياتنا مدمره
خالص انا تعبت ياما انا تعبت فيش احنا مش
عايزين ناكل ولا شرب انا عايزه ارجع داري
انا عايزه ارجع داري هعمل خيمه واقعد فيها
عمل خيمه واقعد فيها لا اله الا الله لا
اله الا الله ومع استمرار هذه الاوضاع
باتت مستشفيات القطاع على حافه الانهيار
في ظل الحاجه الى الدواء والفرق الطبيه
وعدم قدره المستشفيات على استقبال المزيد
من الشهداء
والمصابين صوره هنا وحكايه هناك ترسم
جميعها قصه حرب اسرائيليه مدمره على غزه
طالت البشر والحجره وتنذر بكارثه انسانيه
لم يسبق لها مثيل في الغذاء والماء
والكهرباء والوقود والامدادات الطبيه
هشام زقوت الجزيره من دير البلح وسط قطاع
غزه فلسطين